Anyways,
back to the Hypothalamus,
roughly speaking,
and I'm no expert on hypothalamic
function and I had to pound by way
through Swanson's paper because it's
quite complex,
but the hypothalamus is sort of the
nexus between the brain,
the mind and the body.
That's one way of thinking about it and
it's very good at monitoring your body,
the states of your body and it can
figure out basically when your blood
sugar's too low and when you need water
and when you don't.
Exactly remember how it's,
uh,
associated with the regulation of
breathing because I suspect that that's
a different system and I don't remember
that being a subcomponent of the
hypothalamus,
but it does also regulate things like
sexual behavior and sex,
sexual attraction and temperature
regulation and excretion and,
and you know,
all the things that you would associate
with the basic biological functions that
come along with being a complex animal.
And you know,
we share those functions way down the
evolutionary chain.
You know,
we share a lot of the functions with
everything that moves,
approach and avoidance.
We share with pretty much everything
that moves.
And by the time you get to the higher
mammalian functions,
you know,
we share those with pretty much all
mammals.
That's partly why we can understand
mammals pretty well.
You know,
once you can kind of have a lizard as a
pet and some of them are more social
than others,
but you know,
to really have a pad,
it has to be a mammal and it's even
better if it's a social mammal like a,
like a dog because you know,
you can understand dogs and they can
understand you because they are
hierarchical animals and they have the
same roughly the same set of biological
functions that you do.
You know,
their brains are organized around smell
and not around vision.
And almost all animals are like that
except for people.
And maybe hunting birds,
you know.
So that's one thing that really
distinguishes us from dogs,
but we're similar enough in neuron body
behavior so that we can directly relate
to dogs.
And you know,
they can even play.